is this true that you that you and and
Ben Affleck are working on another
screenplay yeah under the project this
is the first one since hunting yes Good
Will Hunting that's amazing
yeah yeah we wrote it we wrote it with
another writer named an amazing writer
named Nicole hollow Center and it's a
it's we're gonna shoot it next year but
it's about the last sanctioned duel in
medieval France between these two
Knights one of whom claimed the other
raped his wife right and they could not
resolve what had happened and no end and
so they fought to the death to let God
decide who was telling the truth and who
wasn't and so we really it was this all
from the historical record but but we we
thought it was this interesting story of
perspective so Ben and I wrote the male
perspectives and Nicole wrote the female
perspective and Ridley Scott's gonna
direct it yeah yeah so we're really
looking forward to it I think it's
looking forward to that film and Ford
vs. Ferrari I'm telling you it's really
terrific it's in theaters November 15th
and you're gonna love it
Matt Damon what a pleasure thanks